the analogy that astronomers use no
analogy is perfect right we're dealing
with things not just in the three
dimensions of space but in the fourth
dimension of what we call space time so
we have to visualize things that are
really uh unvisualizable by the human
Mind by our own limitations and so we
make analogies so one of the most common
analogies is to think about uh I'll give
you two one is to imagine a balloon with
little dots drawn on the balloon surface
the balloon surface is two-dimensional
as you ex blow up the balloon the
galaxies move away the dots on the
balloon surface move from one another
and they move with exactly that property
that a Galaxy that is one centimeter our
DOT that's one centimeter away from
another galaxy our DOT will move twice
as much in the same amount of inflation
or expansion as a Galaxy that is half a
centimeter separated or a DOT two dots
that are only five millimeters apart
from one another but that's confined to
a two-dimensional surface so it's a
little bit hard to maybe inject that
into three dimensions in our mind so
another one that people use is Imagine
baking a raisin bread so a bread and you
put in a bunch of raisins inside of it
that too has the exact same property if
you sit on any raisin inside the bread
and you watch what are the other raisins
doing that all will be observed to move
away from you there won't be any
gravitational attraction between you and
another raisin
so you'll actually observe what's like a
perfect expansion of the Universe from
your perspective remember I said there
are about 20 or more galaxies that are
gravitationally attracted to the Milky
Way and they are blue shifted because
they're Falling Towards us and will
eventually combine into a enormous Mega
Galaxy called a milk dromeda someday but
that doesn't happen for raisins or for
Dots in a balloon so the law that
describes that type of expansion in
either a raisin bread populated with
raisins in three dimensions or a balloon
dotted with magic marker marks in two
Dimensions those two um those two
phenomena are exactly displaying what's
called Hubble's Law which is the
velocity of every Galaxy we see beyond a
certain distance that's a minimal
distance that we don't have
gravitational interactions between us
and them that Galaxy will be moving away
directly proportional to what's known as
Hubble's Constant so the Velocity in
meters per second miles per hour you
know furlongs per decade whatever you
want will be directly linear it's the
simplest law manageable besides just a
constant it'll be moving linearly
proportionate to its distance away from
you and that's a fascinating observation
and that's the only type of observation
that can produce the type of structures
that we see in the universe in other
words it could have been traveling as
the velocity scaling as the square of
the distance the cube of the distance
the square root of the distance whatever
we would live in a much much different
universe and it wouldn't have any of the
characteristics that we observe
so I think when I read Stephen Hawking's
Brief History of Time which is it's
going to be 20 years ago or
approximately oh it's uh 40 almost 40
years old yeah is it foot guard well
that's what happens when you get old the
decks start to collapse so
um at that point my my memory if my
memory serves me properly
the standard cosmological model was that
we it emerged from a big bang and that
the Universe was expanding but that at
some point it would contract back on
itself and this was Hawking's idea
anyways and then collapsed back down
into uh into another Singularity uh
whatever existed before the Big Bang but
it's my understanding that over the last
few decades the evidence evidence has
accrued in an incontrovertible manner
that the rate of expansion is actually
increasing rather than decreasing and
that's I believe that's the great
mystery that's uh propelled scientists
who posit the existence of such
phenomena as dark energy have I have I
got that right and and what's the
current state of thought about the fact
that first of all explain why that's
surprising uh that the rate of increase
or the rate of expansion is increasing
explain why that's surprising and then
when you explain how that view has
changed over time and where we're at now
absolutely yeah so I got to hear Stephen
Hawking speak at the Royal Astronomical
Society meeting in London in 1995 and it
was back when he couldn't he couldn't
speak for a very long time so he wasn't
able to actually speak in real time but
he could move his fingers and he could
move his eyes and he could type on this
very special keyboard which the
ex-husband of his current nurse at the
time had invented that's a whole other
story I can recommend a book by my
friend Charles seif called Hawking
Hawking and it was sort of the business
of Stephen Hawking and I uh he could
answer one question it would take him
about 10 minutes to answer a question
someone asked him in the audience
Professor Hawking you're rumored to be
the most brilliant man alive and yet
you've written this book that almost no
one besides you know a younger Jordan
Peterson perhaps had red cover to cover
um why did you write this book and he
answered in his computerized synthetic
voice because my daughter needed to pay
for college and uh it was just
interesting that this great man this
great intellect you know trapped in this
body that had you know been robbed of
all of its its physical kind of
maneuvering and so forth was was so
facile with his mind it was really an
incredible thing to see uh when when
Hawking wrote that book it is true uh
the expectation was that the Universe
would eventually collapse on itself
would eventually undergo what's called a
big crunch which is essentially the the
opposite of the Big Bang we would
observe if we were living billions of
years hence the story went that we would
see not galaxies being redshifted but
galaxies being blue shifted because
we're all going to combine and
eventually into a collapse of an
enormous if you like gravitational Time
Bomb uh that would probably play out
over you know billions if not trillions
of years so I kept advising people to
keep pay their taxes but at the at the
at the time we didn't know about the
substance called Dark Energy and what's
so surprising about that and what kept
Einstein really flummoxed for the first
part of his of his career
was that we only knew of a few different
forms of matter and energy in the
universe we knew of matter stuff the
stuff that we're made up of and we knew
of light and in a universe that only has
matter and light it's impossible to not
have a gravitational collapse just as
the same is true if I take an object a
ball or an apple and I throw it up with
some velocity it will still come back
down unless it reaches what's called
escape velocity and the perplex the
perplexing thing about Einstein in
general relativistic gravitation that
still mystifies me and experts is that
when you add matter to the universe it
actually makes it expand faster which is
counter-intuitive you would think if
there was more gravity in the Earth's
surface the ball would or the Apple
would actually fall down even quicker
which it would but uh but in in the case
of when we described the expansion of
the universe we're talking about its
velocity not its acceleration so there's
a crucial distinction the universe can
have objects moving faster away from
each other and that doesn't involve
necessarily their acceleration so what
Einstein did to counteract that fact he
was a pretty smart guy right he looked
around he said well the universe doesn't
seem to be collapsing so there must be
some hidden form of energy that we don't
observe and that unobserved matter he
called the cosmological term or
cosmological energy source we later call
it the cosmological constant and now we
call it dark energy as you as you
proposed what that does is by adding in
matter you get anti-gravity or you add
an energy Pure Energy you get a form of
anti-gravity almost as if you know it's
the comic book Heroes a dream that you
could suspend gravity that you could
freeze the motion of objects that tend
to want to combine with one another so
he and had a mechanism contrived as it
was to explain why the universe appeared
static as it did in 1920 and 1919 but
then as I mentioned earlier when Hubble
observed the universe is in fact not
static hair Einstein the universe is
expanding then Einstein had the
Brilliance the humility and the
confidence to say I was wrong and
supposedly he called the insertion of
the cosmological term his biggest
blunder right now so he was trying to
account for the fact let's just just to
get the chronology clears at that point
the universe appeared static and
Einstein was trying to figure out why it
wasn't collapsing onto itself and so he
proposed a constant which you equated to
something like an anti-gravity energy
but then the problem turned out to be
even worse than it seemed to be because
it was not only not collapsing and not
or sorry not static and not collapsing
it was expanding yeah so and that's the
mystery that people are trying to
address well still today with the
hypothesis of something approximating
dark energy
that's right so the dark energy
phenomenon causes not only a reversal of
the collapse of the universe's in Fall
of all these galaxies or raisins or uh
that would be coming together it not
only freezes them in their tracks it
actually reverses that process so
instead of just expanding linearly
smoothly as Hubble would Envision us
doing actually the universe starts to
accelerate so it's as if you're pushing
down on the cosmic accelerator pedal
these galaxies are not only moving apart
but tomorrow they'll be moving apart
even faster at a given distance they'll
be moving apart faster than they are so
I always joke you know it's uh it was a
blunder of Einstein to call that blunder
his blunder because it wasn't a blunder
at all and I I always say I like to
throw in you know it's too bad that he
made that blunder otherwise he could
have had a good career but in this case
when we when we look at what Einstein
was conjecturing it came back
unavoidably in the late 1990s through
the observation of what are called type
1A supernovae which are just used it's
not important to know what they are
they're exploding stars and they're
fascinating objects in their own right
but they're really used as the sirens on
the ambulances at Great distances so in
uh in in 12 rules for life you talked
about the value of precision of speech
well the most important thing for
cosmologists is precision cosmology when
I started graduate school in the in the
1990s and the mid 90s we didn't know if
the universe was 10 billion years old or
20 billion years old now we know it's
13.824 billion years old and we have a
Precision of less than one percent and
we also have an accuracy in other words
we have calibrated that number and
removed systemic contamination from that
number it's really phenomenal I mean at
that time we knew of objects that were
older than the universe supposedly there
were objects called globular clusters
and they were older than the universe
that's like finding out that you're
older than your mother I mean it's very
bizarre situation and quite frankly it
was embarrassing to cosmologists now we
know with extreme Precision but that
with that Precision comes great power
and that power allows us to assess what
is the nature of this dark energy
potentially
and not only that what is it doing to
our future understanding of where the
universe will continue to develop in the
in the Far Far distant future and so if
the universe truly has this dark energy
chimeric form of energy unknown
completely you know unlike anything
we've ever had an experience with that
type of energy will eventually Drive the
universe potentially in a variety of
different ways none of them good uh but
luckily they don't come about for tens
to perhaps hundreds of billions of years
when the universe might physically rip
apart there could be aspects of
space-time that uh at all locations
develop what we call singularities the
breakdown in all the laws of physics and
certainly long before then we will have
stopped having the ability to do
astronomy or cosmology we will no longer
be able to see any other galaxies after
a certain point after universities
expanded so much those galaxies will all
be redshifted so far out of
observational constraints that we won't
even know we live in a galaxy we'll just
think this is the entire universe so
ironically we'll be back to the way the
State of Affairs was in pre-1929 uh
planet Earth's understanding of
cosmology and with the Precision that I
mentioned before that we know the age of
the universe we know the expansion rate
of the universe we can do astounding
things we can go back in time and ask
just as we do with uh with I remember
when I when my children turned two years
old you take them to the pediatrician's
office
and they measure their height and
basically they've got this rule of thumb
based on the statistics of 100 billion
people that have lived on planet Earth
to date that the child will be about
twice as high twice as tall as he or she
is at age two I think I'm getting that
right I am a doctor but I'm not that
kind of a doctor right so uh you'll have
to check those numbers but they
basically extrapolate so imagine if you
went and you go to the pediatrician and
then you come back in 10 years 15 years
20 years and the kid is like 30 times
bigger than that height or or one-tenth
is tall well you'd say this is crazy
there's something strange going on your
tables are all messed up and and your
actual statistical sample is not a good
representation of the parent population
no pun intended
so the question becomes how accurately
Can you estimate how fast the universe
will be expanding today versus 13
billion years ago and there's what's
called attention because the two numbers
disagree and they disagree by a
violently inacceptable amount they the
measurements that we do with the cosmic
microwave background radiation suggest a
universe that is very in billions of a
billion years
um uh younger if you like than the
universe that we see using the type 1A
supernovae